abone ol
ama ben size teorik bilgiler var yüzde
yirmi olacak bu Işık kedim arkadaşlar
ışıkçı arkadaşımız yüzde yirmi demedin
mi ben Evet peki Arkadaşlar burası iyi
bilgiler vermek için buraya gelmedim ben
size deneyimlerimden bir şeyleri
paylaşmak için buradayım fazla değil 15
yıl önce sizin Oturduğunuz koltuklar da
ben oturuyordum ama İstanbul'da değil
koltuklarda bu kadar rahat değildi
Mersin'de Güzel Sanatlar Lisesi'nde
ahşap sandalye üzerinde oturuyordum
Benim de akıllı bir telefonum yoktu
sosyal medya hesaplarım yoktu
arkadaşlarımı komik videolar
gönderebileceğim bir WhatsApp yoktu
akşam sandalye üzerinde kafamda değil
sorularla cebelleşiyorum üniversite
bittikten sonra Üniversitede hangi
bölümü seçicem Güzel Sanatlar
Fakültesi'nin
O kesin ama hangi bölümü seçeceğim resim
bölümüne gidersen çıkışta resim oluyorum
yani sanatçı hiç Mimarlık grafik gibi
bölümleri tercih edersem çıkınca
tasarımcı oluyorum cam-seramik seçersem
yine sanatçı oluyorum Peki tasarımcıyla
sanatçı arasındaki fark ne mesela
Instagram hesabında kesin dengeli siniz
dir takı tasarımcısı diyen
arkadaşlarımız gerçekten takı
tasarımından mezunlar yoksa çevresinde
bu işi güzel yaptığını düşündüğü için
arkadaşlar Ya sen bence tasarımcısın
arkadaşım sen bunları yapmaya devam et
fimo hamurundan küpelerini yap Instagram
hesabını da tasarımcı olarak 20 dediler
bu ünvanı kendisine layık gördü mesela
gülüş tasarımcıları var şimdi dişçiler
tasarım sektörüne girdiler gülüş
tasarlıyorlar bunların hepsini bir
tarafa atıyorum şimdi Bu sorularıma bu
Gülüşleri size bana bu soruları sorduran
birkaç tane Hani paylaşacağım ilkokul
2'nci sınıfa gidiyorum bir kaza
sonucunda
bu kırıldı arkadaşların yaşıtları
sokakta oyun oynarken ben Hastane
odasında bir tane Yatakta yatıyorum
Mersin'e gelen en gelişmiş teknoloji 37
ekran tüplü televizyon hastanede yok
büyük babam da hediye olarak bana bir
tane getirmiş televizyonda Kral TV açık
Türkçe pop dönüyor Annem seviyorum diye
boyama kitapları almış boyama
kitaplarını boyuyorum bir yandan
akrabalarda seviyorum diye hamurişi
Getiriyorlar bir yandan tatlılar
börekler çörekler Oturduğum yerden
yiyorum Müzik dinle klip izliyorum bir
anda çizim yapıyorum üç buçuk ay
düşünmen iyileşme sürecim Bilin bakalım
neden bir buçuk yıla kadar sürdü yanlış
tedavi nedeniyle kırılan ayağını yanlış
yerden kaynattık ları için bir bacağım
uzak kendi olduğu gibi kalmış
ve yeniden Kırdılar ilk seferinde iki
ayağınıda ağırlık ısırığı bu sefer İki
bacağını da alçıya aldılar Şu pozisyon
dayım squat pozisyonunda Yım şimdi
yapamayacağım yatağa burada düşünün
zemine bu şekilde yatıyorum Beni hareket
ettirebilmek üzeri için araya bir tane
aparat Koymuşlar bir ahşap Çubuk arada
oradan kaldırıyorlar beni Mersin'deyim
yaz günü Mersin'e giden varmı aranızda
Adana Mersin yakınlarında bulunan güneşe
ateş ediyor adamlar yeter olan sıcak
yeter diye yeter altın içerisinde pamuk
var elimde bir tane mi kendimi kaşıyıp
duruyorum kitap okuyorum işe yaramıyor
klip izliyorum şarkı dinliyorum O da bir
yere kadar arkadaşlarım veriyordu sonra
görücülere sınırlama geldi bir iki tane
arkadaşım gelmeye başladı zaman geçmiyor
en sonunda zamanı hızlandırmanın bir
yolu buldum boyamak
bir saat dokuzda başlıyor Bizimkiler
gittikten sonra öğle arası yemek
sonrasında akşama kadar yine çizim
yapıyorum derken tüm boyama kitapları
bitmeye başladı sevdiğim dostlarım
annemin yakınları boyama kitapları
Getiriyorlar ben dekilerin aynısı
Mersin'deki tüm boyama kitaplarını
bitirmişim tüketmiş en sonunda bakıp
böyle boyama kitapları boş kalan yerleri
ne dedin ben Bunun içerisinde yalan
çizimleri buraya geçirin ilk önce
çizimleri yapıyorum bütün çizimler
bittikten sonra yeni bir Boyama kitabım
olmuş gibi hepsini yeniden boyamaya
başlıyorum
ne bunlar böyle devam ederken kafamda
bir ses Merhaba Hayrettin Ben resim
seninle çok güzel bir gelecek
planlıyorum tek yapmam gereken şey bana
biraz daha zaman ayırmak zaten zaman
ayırıyorum ben bu zamanın ayırırken 37
ekranda hala Kral Pop açıktı Türkçe pop
müzikler klipler devam ediyor denk
geldiyseniz bir klip gün içerisinde beş
en az beş defa karşınıza çıkıyor Çünkü
hep aynı şeyi döndürüyorlar ve için
problem değil hoşuma giden klipler
çıktığında zaten izliyorum 27 klibi
izlemeye başlayınca artık Kağıt Sezen
Aksu nun saçını kim yapıyor yani o
kıyafeti o kadına kim gidiyor kendisini
karar veriyor arkada dans edenler
videoları kendimi sergiliyorlar birileri
öğretti onlara ya orası set mi yoksa
birisinin evimi derken başka kliplerde
trampet çalıyor şarkıda trafik Yok kız
gitara Vur ama saçma sapan vuruyor
şarkıyla uymuyor derken bir ses daha
Merhaba Hayrettin Ben müzik
Bu çok güzel bir gelecek planlıyorum
Hazır mısın bana daha fazla vakit
ayırman gerekiyor tek yapman gereken şey
bu kafamda iki soruyla zaten yapacak bir
şey yok Liseye kadar ikisini de
doğurarak bak ilerledim sonra Güzel
Sanatlar Lisesi sınav yaklaştı yapmam
gereken şey ya resmi ya müziği seçmek Bu
resim hocaların resim bölümüne gitsin
diyor müzik öğretmenlerimiz Tabii ki
müzik okusun diyor Annem diyor ki Kendin
Ne biliyorsan onu yap gece yatarken
uyuyamıyorum kafam da peki seçmeli
seçmeli seçmeli şehir resim yapacağız
Hayır Müzik yapacağız sanki birini
seçmezsem diğeri örecek gibi
hissediyorum mecbura resmi çiz seçtim
çünkü Ayağım kırıldı da sanırım ona
biraz daha zaman ayırmışım şu mi 2005
Türkiye'yi rap müzik kasıp kavuruyor şu
anda rapin olduğu gibi o dönemde
alternatif gruplar çıkıyor Çilekeş doğru
yani 3.1 takip edenler vardır belki
aranızda
bu birinci Ben TV'de onları destek
veriyor alternatif gruplara ve de
alternatif müziği Ben de Grup kuracağım
dedim resim bölümüne giderken zaten
resmi besliyorum müzik diyor ki Açım
açım beni doldur beni doyur
ve sonrasında bir görünen arkadaşların
yanına git dedim ki abi bana bir tane
ters 1 tane kontrbus bir kötü kontrbus
yalan birisi de olur bir grup kuralım
akustik olsun sonrasında biz devam
ederiz bunu Rock grubuna çeviri zaten üç
kişilik ilk grubumuzu kurduk grubun adı
dergeç neden Şebnem Ferah Can Kırıkları
albümü çıkarmış 2005'te evdeokul arası
20 dakikalık bir süre Kulağımda kulaklık
yol boyu bağıra çağıra andımızı okudu
gibi şebnemi şarkılarını baştan sonra
söylüyorum İlk böyle giderken hesap
esnaflar bu çocuk ne yapıyor diye
bakıyorlardı anladılar artık şarkı
söylediğimi ona ne sağlıyor bana benim
can kırıklarım var devam ediyorum ben
hayatıma bu aralar sevdiğim şarkılar
hafta içerisinde değiştirmez Pazartesi
Salı Çarşamba Çakıl Taşları seviyorum
cuma cumartesi pazar Okyanus seviyorum
grubun ismini koyacağımız zaman en
sevdiğim şarkı da geçti o yüzden grup
Ne oldu haftanın en az bir gün üstü
düğüne gidiyoruz üç saatlik performansla
gidiyoruz Hem birbirimizi tanıyoruz
prova ediyoruz derken içimdeki müzik
diyor kahretsin resim okuyorsun sen ama
müziğe biraz daha vakit ayırman lazım
Ben bunu doymuyorum Mersin polifonik
Korolar Derneği olarak görev almaya
başladım yandan yahut öğrenmeye
çalışıyorum bir anda bu bahsettiğim Grup
olayı devam ediyor Bir yandan resim
kendi içinde bölündü seramik dersiniz
var grafik dersiniz var Normalde
Ebeveynler Nadir böyle sosyal
aktiviteleri olsun diye çocukları
biraderi göndermeye çalışıyorsun kitap
ders alsın filmi ders alsın çocuğu
yüzmeye öğrensin benim annem diyor ki
bir sakin yapma oğlum bu kadar kendine
yüklenme ne gerek yok bunlardan birini
bırakalım eğer ki o dönemde bu kadar
fazla şeyi bir arada yürüten etseydin ve
bunlarda üretken olmayı deneyim
demeseydim şu anda yaptığım hiçbir işi
yapamayacak tıme aynı anda aynı işleri
yürütmeye çalışıyorum şu anda farklı
işleri bu
ve sonrasında Anadolu Üniversitesi Güzel
Sanatlar Fakültesi iç mimarlık bölümü
üniversite Eskişehir'de okumak isteyen
var mı arkadaşlar Yazık yazık yani şehri
güzelleştiren şey dostluklar Sonrasında
da şehir ama Eskişehir o kadar mükemmel
bir şehir ki Arkadaşlarınıza devam
ettirebilmek için üniversite hayatında
yaşayabilmek için herkes bir daha bakın
bakayım Eskişehir'den olup merak ediyor
diye belgeç grubuna bir tane eleman
geliyor birisi çıkıyor derken biz dedik
ki üniversiteye giderken grubun ismini
değiştirelim yeni bir isimle devam
edelim
Ben o zamanlar tüm bütün hayranıyım tüm
çizimlerini filmlerini takip ediyorum
iyice de içime sinmiş dedim ki artık ben
Gotik bir bireyim ilk önce biraz daha
Punk alternatif bitirdim dedim ki artık
bundan sonra Hayrettin Sen gotik sinsen
gotik sen grubun ismi de Gotik ve Senin
grubunda artık öyle olmak zorunda Kendi
Şarkılarınızı bir anda mesleğimize
çalışıyoruz bir yandan kadınların
üzerinde duruyoruz sizin diğer Grup
arkadaşlarımızın yaptığı gibi bir yandan
da yarışma kullanıyoruz ilk karşımıza
çıkan yarışma Yaris test ve bunu
yüklüyorsunuz ilk ona kalırsanız Küçük
Çiftlik Park'ta sahne oluyorsunuz bu
performansı Arasında ilk üç belirleniyor
şarkı yükledik ilk ona kaldık İstanbul'a
geliyoruz Küçükçiftlik Park'a ne
giyeceğiz
Evet şimdi bir anda müzik devam ediyor
diyor ki Tamam çalışıyoruz üç tane
şarkısını yaziki Beste bir kalır Peki
sahnede ne görecekler izleyiciler güzel
bir kostüm tasarlayalım etli kıyafetler
diken bir tanesi şeydi aldığımız vardı
yanına gittim hazır kıyafetleri var
zaten abla şunu kolunu keselim şunu
bacaklarına kültür siyah Turgut
koyacağız Biz türleri yerim kırmızı
biraz kırmızı var bize kırmızı ekleyelim
derken çok güzel bir performans ve bu
performansı mükemmel bir videosuyla ilk
küçük alamadan eve geri döndük Oğlum ne
kadar güzel bir deneyimdi ya yeni
insanlarla tanıştık kızlar da çok
güzeldi Grup elemanları İstanbul
Küçükçiftlik Park'ta deniyoruz hepimizin
canı sıkkın Çünkü başarısız olduk
yapacak hiçbir şey yok sonrasında Hayal
kırıklıklarından Biz ne yapabiliriz
diyerek Hayal kırıklıkları mızı birşeye
çevirmeye çalıştık daha fazla çalışalım
hedefimiz belli Biz ilk 10A girdi
bu ilçede gireriz ilk önce girdiysek
Birincide oluruz tek yapmamız gereken
şey daha fazla çalışmak çalışmaya devam
ederken yarışmalarda takip ediyoruz
karşımıza çıkan ikinci yarışma patlıcan
Müzik Yarışması bu sefer girerken de u
yüklemiyor sunuz canlı performans
videomuzu yüklemeniz gerekiyor var Bir
önceki performansımızı çok güzel bir
videosu var bu kapıyı açacak anahtar
zaten elimizde hemen video yükledik uzun
bir Piro
bu oylama sonucunda
bu Hayko Cepkin de jüri üyeliği yaptığı
yarışmada birinci olduk Bostancı Gösteri
Merkezi patlıcan Festivali gerçekleşecek
Mor ve Ötesi 3.1 malt ve Manga gibi
gruplar sahne alacak aynı gün içerisinde
bu konserin açılışını ön grup olarak biz
yapıyoruz 21 yaşındayım Kalp krizi
geçireceğim bahsettiğim grupların
dinleyici kitlesi zaten bizim ulaşmaya
çalıştığımız Şu anda da sektörde
organikle organik kitle dedikleri o
kitle zaten karşımızda daha fazla
çalışmamız lazım Bir Ana şarkıları
introlar hazırlıyoruz Bu nakarat olmadı
burayı düzeltelim diyoruz Tamam bunları
devam ederken müzik duyuyor resim diyor
ki Hayrettin okulda eğitim alıyorsun ama
hani yaratıcılık gel senle beraber başka
bir şeyler yapalım yine bak biz takıldık
grubun nasıl görüneceğini ve fazla
bütçemiz yok Prodüksiyon
hazırlayamıyorum işte arkada havai
fişekler çıksın kızlardan sesi gibi bir
şey de yok ortada kostümlerle bir şey
yapacağız dedik hemen klasörleri açtım
batının Türk filmlerini açıp yeniden
beğendiğim sahnelerden ekran görüntüleri
alıp bir klasör oluşturuyorum beğendiğim
şeyler çerçevesinde bir araştırma yapıp
de onları kendi süzgecinden geçirerek
yeni bir şey olarak sunuyorum yani
Adidas ayakkabının aynı modelin alıp
Adidas yazarak insanları sunuyorum çakma
bir şey yapmıyorum kendim gördüğüm şeyi
var olan bir şey yorumlayarak Türkiye'de
Mersin'de bir Gotik nasıl olur diyerek
onu yaratmaya çalışıyorum aslında
Ben bir hafta sonra elimde 7 parça
o ilk kreasyonun hazırdı Gotik kıyafet
kreasyonu Bunlar dikildi ilk önce mental
ablanın yanına yeniden gittim bu sefer
parçalar böyle yok abla yeniden bizim
için yapacağız dedim O da bana dedi ki
ayetin şimdi Buket anne olmaz Biz bunu
likralı an yapacağız O dökümler için
dedi o dönemde şey öğrendim hayalleri
gerçekleştirebilmek için malzeme malzeme
de bilmem gerekiyor Yani likralı hayatım
Artık likralı girdik bir şey Dökümü
istiyorsan gidip Ben Zikri bir kumaş
alabilir miyim diyorum Bunlar dikildi
yan yana geçtik arkadaşlarla beraber
konser öncesi takdir topluyorum ya çok
güzel olmuş Hayrettin ne güzel şeyler
tasarlanmış sın Hayal etmişsin
gerçekleştirmiş sin şimdi baştaki hikaye
dönecek olursam takı tasarımcı arkadaşa
da aynı şeyleri söylüyor arkadaşlar
şimdi ben Moda tasarımcısıyım
Yok böyle bir şey hayal ettin mi yok
Bu neden böyle bir şeyi kendi üzerime
almaya çalışıyorum veya böyle bir şey
bize söylenince Evet ben Instagram
hesabıma bile moda tasarımcısı yazayım
diyorum Bunlar da bir köşeye atıyorum
şimdi O soruları Orada kalsın size bu
bahsettiğim hikâyelerden
o öncesinde şarkının hikayesini
anlatayım Bu bahsettiğim resimli müzik
mi beni seç sanki bir yola girersem
gerisini Seçen diğerini seçebilecek
mişim gibi geri dönemeyecek mişim gibi
resmi seçtikten sonra müziği hiçbir
şekilde de sap alacakmışım gibi
hissettim dönemlerde Yolumu kaybettim
isminde bir şarkı yazdım şimdi
izleyeceğiniz performansta o kadar şey
de bilmiyorum hangi akoru bastığımı
Sadece hissiyat olarak hakimin bu konuya
cep telefonunda altyapısını hazırladım
ya bu klibinin Bu şarkının klibi Nasıl
olsa diye düşünüp sevdiğim videolardan
bir kolay hazırladım size üzerinde canlı
performans şarkı söyleyeceğim verseniz
iyi olur
Evet hocam Işık kümesi Al her şeyi kimse
hiçbir şey görmesin
ama hepsi kırmızıdal
İyi ki bu yollarda da
bu duyulardan dır şu mı Ben Yolumu
Kaybettim kendimi kendim nefesini hiçbir
şey çok sağ ol
bu ara klems izlerken ellerinizin de Ben
Yolumu Kaybettim yokmuş ki yollarda
[Müzik]
yollarda mı
Ya ben Yolu kaybettim zarar mı ömrüm
kuşlara bu uzansam düşen uyuyorlar
ayaklarımız O
o olmasaydı daha güzel bir şey
planlamıştım ama umarım beğenmişsinizdir
Arkadaşlar sağ ol teşekkür ederim Şimdi
Şuradaki alayım sanatçı genel olarak
bu soru sorar tasarımda cevap verir bu
izlediğiniz performansla mesela sanatçı
mı yaptı dersiniz bir tasarımcı mı yaptı
dersiniz yoksa bence bu hem sanatçı hem
de tasarımcının bir arada yaptığı bir
çalışma mı dersiniz yoksa ağabey bana ne
ben çok güzel bir performans izledim ben
buna bir ünvan vermeme gerek yok mu
dersiniz
Bu Arif gibiyim arkadaşlar barsana küçük
bir deneyim daha iyi şeyi beraber
buradan ayrılmak istiyorum Normalde ben
salon şarkıcıyım ya koridor şarkıcıyım
oturduğumuz evlerin hepsinde ince uzun
bir koridor vardı bu kurduğum kapılarını
kapatıp en sevdiğim Eko orada oluyordu
banyo daha soğuk ekosu güzel ama ben
koridorları daha çok seviyordum
üniversite hayatında da bu ince uzun
koridorlar beni takip etti arkadaşları
toplayıp gelin toplanın Siz istediğiniz
şarkıları söyleyeceğim diyordum alttaki
tarih bir şey yok çıplakses şarkı
söylüyorum onlara şimdi oyuncu uzun
koridorlardan böyle geniş bir salonda
sizinle bu dönemi yaşayalım istiyorum
altta hiçbir şey olmadı ama ben size bir
tane şarkı söyleyeceğim
on numara beğenirseniz Buradan mı
başlayalım mı şimdi Hadi sizi şimdi
koridora götüremediği için burada o
Etkin yaratalım dedik tamam mı kafandan
kovalamaya çalışınca dökülür Konuyu çok
uzatmadan Bunun neresi a
da başka bir Sizlerde kalmıştık aradan
sonsuzda Sultan arıza sormaya çekil
dudağındaki ipini koparmış keyfi bir gün
[Müzik]
çoktan ayrıldık sormaya çekinirim
dudağındaki koparmış keyfi bir gün de
Evet şimdi şurada ra ra ra ra ra ra ra
ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra ra
ra ra kalmıştı çok zor sormaya de
bu ipini koparmış keyfi bir güne
Ligi'nde Geldik Çok teşekkürler
arkadaşlar eğlenceler mı